joe biden threatens to nuke gun-owning
americans chairman of the joint chiefs
general mark milley defends teaching
critical race theory in the military
and democrats reap the whirlwind as
crime skyrockets i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with vpn
i trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you may have noticed
that you
are spending way too much money on your
cell phone bill and you are you're
spending probably hundreds of dollars a
year too much on your cell phone
this is why another thousand of you my
extremely wise listeners have made the
switch from your overpriced wireless
carrier to pure talk usa over the past
couple of months
so what exactly are the rest of you
waiting for if you're worth a t verizon
or t-mobile your family could save over
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number
but you're going to save a fortune by
the way pure talk is the
top rated wireless company by consumer
affairs with the absolute best
customer service team based right here
in america if that sounds good
it gets even better right now get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it grab your
mobile phone dial pound 250 say ben
shapiro when you do you'll say fifty
percent off your first month dial pound
two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk is
simply
smarter wireless go check them out right
now all you have to do dial pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started that's
pound 250
and say my name ben shapiro to get
started with pure talk usa
all righty so last night we learned
kind of what joe biden and the democrats
and his entire administration think the
military
is for and apparently it is for two
things one is nuking americans and the
second
is critical race theory i'm not sure
what else i'm supposed to take away from
the news cycle
yesterday given the fact that the
sitting president of the united states
and when i say sitting i mean that very
literally i mean he has a house plan he
is just
sitting there he is not mentally able he
is not with us
he has not been with us for quite some
time he was trying to make the case
that the big spike in crime that we have
seen over the course of the last year
has nothing to do with lack of police
and everything to do with guns so as
we'll discuss in a little bit
he's been making the pitch that we need
to get rid of guns in american society
to lower crime
which is kind of an amazing contention
given the fact that we now have more
guns in circulation
than we've had any time in american
history and everything was going pretty
swimmingly up until the time the
democrats decided that it would be great
to foment riots in america's major
cities
and undercut the police but in any case
joe biden then made a sort of peculiar
argument so he was talking
about people who believe in the second
amendment as a form of defense against
the infringement of your rights by the
government which of course was the
original purpose of the second amendment
i mean the second amendment's text says
pretty much as much
the the second amendment's text suggests
that in order to defend your rights
you are going to be able to keep and
bear arms right a well-regulated militia
not meaning regulated by the state a
well-regarded meaning a practiced
militia being necessary to the security
of a free state the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed right so right in the
amendment
there's the preferatory clause which is
all about the rationale for having arms
and it is all about preserving the
freedom of the state
preserving your freedom against the
government right and so
a lot of people like me have made the
argument that one of the reasons why you
need an armed population
is to provide a deterrent against the
government invading your rights
it's one of the good things about having
an armed population is that the
government
can't get too much over its skis without
running pretty headlong
into a population that is unhappy with
that government and that makes the
government think twice
about whether they in fact want to go to
war with their own citizens according to
biden however
all of this is uh is nugatory it doesn't
make any difference
because in the end we could just nuke
you now
i'm old enough to remember when eric
swalwell said the same thing you know
eric swalwell
who uh was at one point split sleeping
with a chinese spy apparently
but that's beside the point joe biden
seems to think this is an intelligent
point because he's made it several times
in the past
and it continues to be astonishingly
idiotic on a wide variety of levels but
the
basic notion that you should respond to
any question in american politics with
well you know the government could just
nuke you i think i want a gun now
like really if the case that you are
making is that
you should not own guns because your
government could just kill
you i'm pretty sure now i want guns more
than i did before you just said that joe
biden
that is that is a galaxy brain take here
from a man whose synapses stopped firing
long ago
here is a the president of the united
states
who's looking more and more these days
like one of those chia pets like
the hair plugs are all that's left atop
the it's just it's not a good look here
is the
the president of the united states those
who say the blood of the
the blood of patriots you know and all
the stuff about how we're going to have
to
move against the government well the
tree of liberty is not water in the
blood of patriots what's happened is
that there are never been if you want to
think you need to
have weapons to take on the government
you need f-15s and maybe some
nuclear weapons you know because you
ever otherwise will
well like just your driver f-15 said
we'll drive them
over your boards and then we'll just
drop some boom
i like explosions measured like
well done mr president by the way i i do
love i it is fairly amazing how
inconsistent the arguments are from
people like joe biden on this sort of
stuff
you'll recall that simultaneously the
president of the united states is
arguing
that it would make no difference if the
population is armed because obviously we
can just send f15s to nuke your hometown
and you know kill all these civilians in
your area and
do like all right man captain human
rights over here
but not only that this is the same
person who continues to argue the entire
democratic party and media continue to
argue that on january 6th
we were this close to the overthrow of
the american democracy
the american experiment was this close
to being like it was really a
a close call thing when a bunch of idiot
droogs decided to run into the capitol
building now
not one of those idiot droogs actually
in the capitol building
was arrested with a gun so far as i'm
aware at this point okay there has been
one per there have been i think three
people charged
with firearms related to the capital
riots
one was on the capitol grounds right
outside the building
one had been like planning with guns but
didn't actually show up and one was
outside in a truck with like a molotov
cocktail
but apparently a bunch of citizens were
not armed with guns
came this close to completely
overrunning the most powerful military
state in the history of mankind
and so so recognize the relative
inconsistency here according to joe
biden
an entirely armed population with ar-15s
couldn't take on the federal government
but a bunch of morons wearing maga hats
could take over the entire federal
government by walking through the front
doors
carrying clubs i'm not sure i see the
consistency
here okay but on a deeper level
the way that joe biden sees the
government is sort of betrayed by what
he says here
you need to and it's it's true you need
to listen to the government
because the government could just kill
you you don't need
x y or z tool because after all you
can't resist the government if the
government decides to invade your rights
so really you are just dependent on the
government being nice to you
and what the military is for is to deter
american citizens the american military
is there to effectively enforce the
leftist prerogatives
right this is what imagine if donald
trump had threatened to nuke american
citizens
it was bad enough when he threatened to
quote unquote nuka hurricane right this
is a big national story
you have the current president of the
united states saying this and he's said
this over the years many times
that you know you don't need guns
because absolutely we could just nuke
you
and everybody just doesn't bat an eye
because in the view of the left the
notion of the american government nuking
its own citizenry
is like j it's just a natural corollary
of the fact that the federal government
is supposed to run your life so
apparently the military is for two
things one is nuking american citizens
who refuse to go along
with the program and are armed and the
second thing of course the military is
there
in order to affect social change right
on the list of of things that the
military is there to do
teach gay rights push racial radicalism
not defend the nation really we need to
get rid of a lot of the funding
and let's face it america's history of
military conquest imperialism and
colonialism is just
horrifying according to the left but the
military exists there to deter american
citizens from doing bad stuff
which again is sort of legal under the
posse commentators act and also
it is there to to affect social change
from one of our great national
institutions we'll get to that aspect of
the military in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that you should always be prepared
in the case of an emergency of 2020 if i
say anything is that it is pretty good
to be prepared in your home in case god
forbid something goes wildly wrong
now is a better time than any to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options
ready wise has a lot of options like
emergency meals free dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking and
camping other outdoor activities food
prices continue to increase
take control of tomorrow make sure your
family is ready with plenty of reliable
nutritional meals for when it matters
most
ready-wise the leader in emergency food
supplies makes being prepared simple
and affordable their delicious meals
have up to a 25-year shelf life and are
simple to make
just add water order online have
emergency food shipped directly
to your doorstep readywise is offering
exclusive pricing for my listeners visit
readywise.com
shapiro save up to 50 off emergency food
and supplies that is r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com shapiro for exclusive pricing go
check them out
right now again that's readywise.com
save up to 50
off emergency food and supplies and be
prepared
for any emergency that is to come
alrighty so
military is there for two purposes one
of course is to possibly nuke the
american citizens who
have the temerity to be armed i also
love the assumption here by joe biden
that if it came down to the american
military going to war with its own
citizens
members of the military would just take
the order and start murdering american
citizens willy-nilly
i have some doubts about that one but
the other thing that the military is
there to do is affect social change now
here
i have to make a large-scale distinction
between the
on the ground soldiers between the
people who serve in the military at a
lower level
and the political generals this has
always been true it is true in nearly
every arena of public life it's true for
cops and police chiefs for example
there are many police officers all
around the nation who wildly disagree
with the politicization of their police
departments and the use of their police
departments to grab down policy that is
bad right you see this
in major americans i talk to cops all
the time who disagree
with the people who very often reach the
top echelons of police work because
in order to become police chief in a
major city you have to kiss a lot of ass
and you have to do a lot of political
manipulation well the same thing is true
if you are to become a forest star
general if you talk to people who are
sort of serving in the mid ranks if
you're talking to colonels you're
talking to captains you're talking to
sergeants
if you're lieutenant if you're talking
to any other officer rank
even low-level generals who have not
reached sort of the highest levels they
will tell you that there is a group of
political generals and in order to get
there i mean this is true in literally
any company and it's true
in the military as well in order to get
there you have to politically maneuver
and kiss a lot of but and you have to
make sure that you're mirroring the
priorities of the political branches
of the united states government or at
least you think you do if you want to
get ahead
which is why we saw yesterday the
bizarre spectacle
of the us's top military leader army
general mark milley chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
yeah basically getting angry at
lawmakers for asking
about the sort of ideology being taught
to soldiers
in the united states army and because
the reality is that if you look at the
recommended reading list
for the us military right now it is
filled with what crap
it really is okay so here is general
milley
suggesting that you can't don't call the
military well we're not we're not woke
we're just teaching
wokeness but we're not we're not woke
and if you ask questions it's
unpatriotic now the leftist
has jumped on this because the left
which has spent
pretty much of its entire existence
declaring the united states military
military
an armed wing of u.s imperialism and
colonialism which has declared the us
military one of the worst institutions
on the planet
now the left is saying it's unpatriotic
if you point out that the u.s military
is being used
as an engineer of social change in a
really deleterious way to both military
morale and to the country's future here
is a general mark millie in defense
however
i personally find it offensive that we
are accusing
the united states military our general
officers our commission non-commissioned
officers
of being quote woke or something else
because we're studying some theories
that are out there that was started at
harvard law school years ago and it
proposed
that there were laws in the united
states anti-bellum laws prior to the
civil war
that led to a power differential with
african-americans that were
three-quarters of a human being when
this country was formed and then we had
a civil war and emancipation
proclamation
to change it and we brought it up to the
civil rights act in 1964 it took another
hundred years to change that
so look it i do want to know okay so the
this is the part where it's pretty well
right so you see
how what millie is doing he's hiding
behind these other soldiers and how dare
you call that sergeant wilke i'm not
calling on sergeant woke i'm saying that
you are teaching wokeness
in the united states military when you
assign ibram x kendi as recommended
reading
and michelle alexander has recommended
reading you know what time the military
has recommended reading lists they took
a look at this yesterday
now it's not it so so millie frankly was
not telling the truth here
okay so he's not telling the truth for a
couple of things one all americans
for a long time have known about things
like slavery and the three-fifths clause
and the civil war they've known about
jim crow we've known about the civil
rights act this has been taught
in every history class in the united
states since i was a child
and i was a child now kind of a long
time ago
at least 20 years ago it was taught to
my my parents when they were post
college right i mean like
like the the notion that americans just
don't know about things like slavery or
that you need critical race theory
in order to teach this it's a lie he's
conflating
what normal american history is and how
it should be taught with critical race
theory which suggests that every
institution of the united states
is rife with racism and rooted in racism
and inextricably intertwined with racism
this is a game that the critical race
theory proponents like to play
it's this martin bailey game where if
you actually call out what critical race
theory is
they just go oh no no we're just trying
to teach regular american history and
you know it's just a legal analytical
tool
okay first of all if critical race
theory is an analytical tool it's the
crappiest analytical tool of all time
the worst kinds of analytical tools are
single lens analytical tools
what i mean by that is there is no good
analysis that is a single factor
analysis
there is no one skeleton key that
unlocks any issue
it's true with regard to your life it is
true with regard to politics
if you look at anything just through one
lens you are likely to get it completely
wrong what critical race theory does is
it says that all
other sort of intervening effects that
have led to inequality of outcome
are irrelevant racism is the only thing
that could lead
to any sort of inequality of outcome
that doesn't make it an analytical tool
it's the opposite of a tool it is a
weapon it's a weapon to be used against
the systems itself and the people who
created the system admit as much
i read to you from richard delgado and
gene stefancek two of the founders of
critical race theory who openly say this
stuff okay so mark milley is not telling
you the truth he is lying here
okay and then he continues you know how
dare you call the military woke
how did you can't call the military woke
i just want to understand white rage
um i'm pretty sure now you're just
speaking wokeness here
the united states military academy is a
university uh
and it is important that we train and we
understand
uh and i i want to understand white rage
and i'm white
and i want to understand it so what is
it that caused
thousands of people to assault this
building
and try to overturn the constitution of
the united states of america what caused
that
i want to find that out okay this is
propagandistic i mean
like really that's insane this is the
leading military
man in the united states government
explaining he wants to check into the
roots of white but don't worry he's not
woke guys and if you call him woke and
if you suggest that he's promoting this
woke garbage
then there's something wrong with you
you're being unpatriotic so wokeness is
now patriotism which is incredible
because wokeness is overtly
anti-patriotic
wokeness is about undermining the
fundamental basis of the united states
saying that the declaration is a lie
saying the constitution is a lie
saying the institutions of the united
states are mere facades
for hierarchies of power instituted in
order to subjugate black americans
and this guy's sitting there being like
and if you challenge me on this you're
unpatriotic
unreal unreal i want to understand what
but don't worry we're not indoctrinating
the soldiers and and people in our
military the people who ought to be the
most patriotic considering they are
literally putting their lives on the
line for the institutions wokeness is
trying to eviscerate
if you say that he's doing something
wrong that means that you are
unpatriotic by the way other books
besides x kennedy include sexual
minorities in politics by jason
pierceson which casts any opposition to
the lgbt agenda items
as grounded in animus i mean it's very
open in the introduction of this book
and promotes michelle foucault's
attempted obliteration of the private
public distinction
saying that your sex life is basically
public policy also michelle alexander's
new jim crow which suggests
that racial differentials and arrest
statistics are solely due
to the fact that policing in the united
states is racist that is recommended
in the military reading list but don't
worry they're not in dog and if you
if you challenge how dare you challenge
sergeant bill over here i'm not
challenging
challenging sergeant bill i'm saying you
are a political general who is doing the
bidding of the biden administration
period end of story that is not a
challenge
to his courage in combat i don't know
his his actual
combat record or anything i assume that
it is better than mine i'm not in the
military
this is not challenging what he has done
for the country over the cour
it's challenging what he's doing right
now as a political general and that is
what he is once you're at the top you're
inherently political
in a second we'll get you more of this
what the military is for
first let us talk about how you educate
your kids as you can see there are
forces out there that wish to educate
your kids in a wide variety of the
anti-traditional values ranging
from wokeness to transgenderism now all
of these
sorts of indoctrination centers exist
in american public life and particularly
are directed at children prageru is now
launching a massive new k-12 education
program
thousands of educators and parents have
already signed up check it out at
prageru.com
kids prageru has tons of free kids shows
books magazines with the pro-american
values that aren't being taught in
schools or most kids shows
the prageru website has everything you
need to get your young family through
what is happening in our country right
now
do you want your kids to learn about our
nation's founding principles and be
proud of them how about passing on
values you care about
like truth freedom responsibility hard
work equality under god if you want your
kids consuming content
that actually supports your values go to
prageru right now show your children
their animated shows books and magazines
most importantly
support prageru in their efforts to take
back america's education subscribe now
don't miss prageru's incredible free
kids content that is prageru.com
kids today again go check them out
they're basically our sister company we
love the folks at prageru they're doing
wonderful work
check them out right now prageru.com
forward slash kids today
okay so mark mellie continues along
these lines so first he says
i'm insulted that you're calling the
military woke no
just just you and the infrastructure
that's pushing this stuff and then he
immediately starts citing
talking points about white rage by the
way notice how he just slides in there
i want to understand what happened on
january 6th okay the white rage talking
point
this is just a bunch of white racists
who invaded the capital on january 6th
there may have been and there were some
white racists who invaded the capital
also i assume there were just a bunch of
people who were pissed off about the
election but weren't actually members of
neo-nazi groups
but again there is no evidence necessary
in order to declare anything in american
life racist
i mean we're doing this whole
quote-unquote racial reckoning on the
false basis that derek chauvin
murdered george floyd because he was a
racist when not a single iota of
evidence was brought to that effect
okay and then mark milley does the
mountain bailey routine what's wrong
with trying to
teach members of our military the about
our country it's just regular history
no it is not regular history it is
history that is twisted
and perverted and in many cases ignored
in order to provoke the notion that
america is a very very bad place why
would you possibly teach that to members
of the military
you may have noticed that when it comes
to real politic
world power it's a zero-sum game do you
think members of the chinese military
today
are learning about the historic evils of
even the malice regime
i have serious doubts do you think that
the members of the russian military
are sitting around learning about the
evils
of the russian system i don't think so
but this is what the military is for
it's for social engineering here's mark
miller pushing it
i want to maintain an open mind here and
i do want to analyze it it's important
that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians they come from the
american people
so it is important that the leaders now
and in the future
do understand it i've read miles seitang
i've read
i've read karl marx i've read lenin that
doesn't make me a communist
so what is wrong with understanding
having some situational understanding
about the country for which we
are here to defend okay but here is the
thing okay this is such a
look at that look at the sort of
sophistry here yes he's read mao
to oppose it he's red lenin to oppose
it he didn't read it as like well maybe
we should actually take seriously the
protestations of lenin
and then maybe we should you know see
our country and the way lenin's our
country
there's a reason that mao and lenin are
not on the recommended reading list of
the united states military because there
are certain ideologies that run directly
counter
to the basic notions that americans are
fighting for when they join the american
military
among those notions are identity
politics and yes critical race theory
and yes communism which is why none of
those should be on the recommended
reading list for members of the american
military
this is insanity okay the american
military is not a place
where you are supposed to be exploring
your beliefs
on franz fanon okay that is not what the
us military is for it is a fighting
force
but not anymore it's just for social
engineering here's millie against oh
it's just about openness it's just about
openness and
and learning to be critical and really
weird it's strange to me
i will admit it is very strange to me
the notion that the american military is
supposed to be achieving the same
function as cal state northridge
that's strange to me i'll just put that
out there here's mark milley defending
the notion
on the issue of critical race theory etc
i'll obviously have to get much smarter
on
whatever the theory is um but i do think
it's important
actually uh for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read
okay that's fine be open-minded be
widely read you don't recommend
to read as like these again he's not a
signing
heather mcdonald's the war on cops
alongside michelle alexander is the new
jim crow
okay that is not that is not what he is
doing right there
nothing like it this is not about
open-mindedness this is about
indoctrination of course of course
okay but the good news is that we're
really doing the important things right
like um
nellis air force base the other day
really did something important they had
their first ever
drag queen show at its on-base dining
and entertainment clubs according to a
base spokesperson according to nellis
air force base they said in an email to
breitbart news
nellis air force base and the 99th air
base wing hosted its first ever
drag show thursday june 17th at the
nellis club the event was sponsored by a
private organization provided an
opportunity
for attendees to learn more about the
history and significance of drag
performance art within
the lgd lgbt plus community
ensuring our ranks reflect and are
inclusive of the american people is
essential so the moral cohesion and
readiness of the military yes drag shows
are now essential to the morale cohesion
and readiness of the military nellis air
force base is committed to providing and
championing an environment that is
characterized by equal opportunity
diversity and inclusion wow
i mean our military is just how how will
the chinese ever compete with us
how will the russians ever compete with
us we're doing the important work here
we're doing the work
drag queen shows michelle alexander max
kendy
and maybe if you have a gun we'll nuke
you
beautiful this isn't dystopian in any
way shape or form
in a second we're gonna get into more
dystopian
nonsense from the democrats first let us
talk for a second
about the basic reality of sleep you
need a great set of sheets on your bed
now you probably haven't thought about
the sheets on your bed
probably you know i went down to the
local
mart and you just bought whatever she
said they're like oh it's got a high
thread count this is probably
comfortable and now you are sleeping on
a tarp
instead you should have the best sheets
because sheet quality makes a huge
difference when it comes to sleep and
this is why i love my bowl
and branch sheets experience
uncompromising comfort with the
best-selling 100 organic
cotton signature hemmed sheets the cloud
weight supersoft satin weave gets softer
with every single wash it is crafted to
the highest standards attention to
detail from sourcing to packaging it's
the perfect balance of weight and
breathability to pamper warm or cool
sleepers through any season give your
bed the white house treatment with
sheets that three presidents have fallen
in love with i love bull and branch as
well it really is fantastic
and they have a 30 night worry free
guarantee if you're unsatisfied with
the product go check them out right now
to experience an entirely new standard
of comfort visit bull
and branch dot com i love my bowling
brand sheets my wife loves the bowling
brand sheets we got them for the kids as
well get 15
off your first set of sheets with promo
code shapiro that is b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code shapiro
bowl and branch dot com
promo code shapiro alrighty so meanwhile
the the democrats are in a bit of
trouble
so here's the thing they're pushing
forward with this radical agenda
in the military in every area of
american life actually
and this stuff is not popular
for some reason democrats seem to think
that twitter is real
now there's a study that came out from
pew research that i think is quite
important on this topic
the study came out october of 2020 and
what it showed
is that basically twitter is dominated
by democrats
what they found is that most u.s adults
on twitter post only rarely but a small
share of highly active users most of
whom are democrats produce
the vast majority of tweets the pew
research center
found that just 10 percent of users
produced 92 percent
of all tweets from u.s adults since last
november so it's an echo chamber right
between the 10 of users producing 92 of
the tweets
69 of these highly prolific users
identify as democrats or democratic
leaning independents what this means
is that number one the platform has a
larger share of democrats than
republicans number two
because it's an echo chamber in which
the most powerful people are democrats
and the most frequent tweeters are
democrats
it's easier to ratio a republican than a
democrat and it's easier to get tons of
retweets if you're a democrat than a
republican
and this leads people into a belief that
the democratic wild progressive agenda
is significantly more popular than it is
it simply is not a good proof of this
david french pointed this out and it's a
great point
andrew yang had nearly 2 million twitter
followers during the new york mayoral
race eric adams had fourteen thousand
eric adams just skunked andrew yang
because the real world
is not twitter if the same thing was
true in bernie sanders versus joe
bidenville
twitter is not the real world yet
because that is the source of news
and people are inevitably biased by the
news that they consume
people on the left viewing twitter as
the real world as opposed to an echo
chamber tend to think that their
policies are much more popular than they
are then they enact those policies and
it turns out the policies suck
they're nowhere is this truer than when
it comes to policing and crime
so the democrats are about to get their
asses handed them in 2022 on the issue
of crime
the crime rates in the united states
have skyrocketed they'd already started
skyrocketing
before the riots in 2020 they actually
started skyrocketing in 2014-2015 with
the ferguson riots
and then it calmed down a little bit and
then in 2020 they just exploded you're
seeing the murder rates in virtually
every major metropolitan area dominated
by democrats
just unbelievable numbers unbelievable
numbers
and members of the police forces are
pointing this out so for example the
lapd police chief
he said you know we were beating back
crime we're doing a pretty good job of
it and now that's all gone
we've led the country in crime reduction
over this past decade we've shown that
cops count for police matter
that community engagement is the leading
aspect of crime prevention
and that crime reduction also is tiered
that is tied to
effective policing identifying those
that are involved in the violence
bringing them before the justice system
and holding them accountable all of that
in this last year
has been terribly and devastating
devastatingly impacted
okay so the reality of course is that
crime in los angeles is up
wildly year over year the the murder
rate is up like 25
and that is not a great shock we've seen
the same thing in every major american
city so the democrats have been faced
with a simple reality
and that is that their preferred
policies with regard to the cops blaming
the cops for all racial disparities and
crime statistics
suggesting that getting rid of the cops
is the solution to all of this blaming
systemic racism none of this is actually
solving the problem
of actual crime in which people get hurt
or killed
so they've come up with a few different
strategies one is to deny there is a
problem
so for example you have dc mayor mural
bowser who's big
whose most important contribution to
fighting crime
was painting a giant black lives matter
mural on the streets of washington dc
and then watching as many of her
citizens just got shot in the street
she went on in front of the senate
and she claimed that there was only one
night of rioting in dc last summer which
is weird because there are literally
millions of people who remember dc being
curfew for like a week
do you have a property damage estimate
from the summer riots
i'm i'm glad to hear you say that you
are
opposed to riotous behavior whether it
happened
on 16th street or here matt madame could
you could you could you answer the
question do you have an
estimate of the property damage during
the summer riots i know that we had
one night of um rioting
in the district do you know do you know
how many people do you know how many
people were arrested for the summer
riots
uh we've had dozens of people arrested
over the last year
okay so um pretty impressive denial that
anything went wrong in washington dc
under her auspices even though
again i know lots of people who are
living in washington dc who are
basically bunkered down in their
apartment
for a week on end while people ran
roughshod through the city
hey that's one strategy one strategy to
downplay this you saw this from mayor
laurie lightfoot yesterday she did the
same exact thing in chicago she said no
no crime is actually down
from last year when it was up
dramatically so really well done
the the other strategy is to deny that
democrats are behind you sort of defund
undercut the police
routine in the first place so this is
pushed by senator maisie hirono
legitimately the stupidest member of the
united states senate from hawaii
suggesting that democrats don't stand
for defunding the police oh interesting
because
it seems like um kind of your vice
president was calling to bail out
rioters
last year and also joe biden suggested
shifting funding away from the cops and
towards social workers
and also there's been an attempt by the
biden doj to crack down on police
departments across the country
don't worry they're not anti-cop the
democrats do not
stand for defunding police the police
have a major role to play especially
community policing and reducing
the incidence of violence and crime in
our communities but it is a multifaceted
issue and concerns and that's how we
should approach it
it is not all about let's just get tough
on
crime it's not about we'll just get
tough on crimes it's not about defunding
the police but also
it's not about getting tough on crime
also we're not against defunding the
police except for you know those of us
who are like india walton who just
won the buffalo mayoral primary democrat
explaining that um their plan is to
shift money away from the cops and put
it toward quote unquote community
development so this is going well
my plan is to put our resources into
community into neighborhoods and
govern in a deeply democratic way that
the people who are governed have
say over the decision-making process and
how resources
are deployed in our community hmm so
yeah they're not against defining the
police except when they're completely
free funding the police but here's the
good news they can also blame
republicans for defunding the police
that's literally what jen saki tried to
do
she literally i mean this is so the the
gall of this is
pretty rich so you have an entire
democratic party that has embraced the
notion that systemic racism and american
policing
is what ails the united states in terms
of both race relations and crime
and then you have gensake get up there
and say oh yeah and it's republicans who
want to defund the police
yeah lady i mean my god not all of us
are double-digit iqs here part of his
announcement is also
ensuring their specific guidance to
communities across the country to ensure
that they have funding to get
more community police around the country
something that was supported by
the american jobs plan that was
supported that was voted into law by
democrats just a couple of months ago
some might say that
the other party was for defunding the
police i'll let others say that but
that's a piece you see it's cute because
in the infrastructure package that was
two trillion dollars there's like five
bucks for the cops and then they voted
against it so
they hit the hahaha i mean it's
unbelievable
the gas lighting so remember this was
their agenda and now they have to run
away from their own agenda
joy behar did the same thing she blamed
trump for rising crime
yes probably it was the president who
was calling for law in order
the same president you were screaming at
screaming at
for suggesting perhaps we might use the
insurrection act quell riots in most of
america's major cities the same
president you were yelling at for
putting federal troops
in place or federal officers rather in
places like portland to protect federal
property
probably it was him yes joy it wasn't
you it was him
every president since clinton inherited
a basically a declining
crime rate and then continue it
continued to decline
until trump came along because trump
resided over the greatest crime rise
in modern american history the murder
rate shot up 26 percent
and mass shootings have spiked hate
crimes spiked more than 20
during his presidency now i don't want
to lay the whole thing at his feet
but he did create four years normalizing
crime
four years normalizing crime what in the
actual
f like seriously okay but joe biden
has the most incredible response to all
of this again you can't just say
we need to step up on the cusp which is
amazing because remember
joe biden's signal accomplishment when
he was in congress was the 1994 crime
bill which was a win
the 1994 crime bill magnified the
ability
of the police to staff up and led to an
unprecedented drop in the violent crime
rate in the united states
basically unparalleled in american
history from 1994
all the way until about 2014. and now he
can't even own that so now he's got an
alternative explanation for why crime
rate
has been driven up in the united states
don't worry it's not the cops
being absent it's not the cops being
undercut it's not the democrats
fomenting riots and looting and
justifying it and pretending it's all
part of a giant racial reckoning that
the united states deserves
and ripping on the institutions of the
united states it's not any of that
it's guns of course we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's talk about how comfortable you are
at the office so you're going to the
office
you're going to sit there all day you'll
be sitting on an uncomfortable rickety
office chair
it's just not very nice okay or there is
a plausible alternative
you could be sitting on a cloud from
heaven now i'm talking right here
about the x-chair x-chair has you
covered for your office chair needs the
x-chair
can give you a massage while you're
sitting at your desk it can warm your
back on cold mornings it can cool you
off on hot days it is a magical mystical
machine
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support which
offers unbelievable lumbar support to
your lower back now
they've introduced elemex featuring
cooling heat and massage therapy
imagine regulating your body temperature
and getting massage therapy while you're
sitting at your desk
the extra lmx cooling delivers heat and
massage technology directly to your core
helping to increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy all perks that make
working from home or the office a joy
lmax even offers four different massage
modes and fast warming heat technology
for therapy to your sore back
it's an unbelievable thing extra prices
are going up july 11th for the first
time in two years so right now is the
time to beat the price increase
go to xchairshapiro.com right now that
is the letter x
chair shapiro.com or call one eight four
four four x chair to get 100 bucks off
your order extra is a 30 day guarantee
of complete comfort you can finance in
your purchase for as little as 30 bucks
a month go to xchairshapiro.com right
now
use code x wheels for free
xwheelbladecasters xchairsshapiro.com
go check them out right now alrighty
we'll get to more on this in just a
second
first joe biden hasn't even been
president for six months already his
agenda's a complete mess
whether it is democratic senator joe
manchin blocking biden's beloved
supposed voting rights bill or border
czar kamala harris getting ripped for
not visiting the border she finally is
visiting it just took a few months
it seems the dividend administration
they're having some trouble but
leftists meanwhile are in fact
succeeding in their cultural takeover
or maybe they're not maybe the cracks
are beginning to show states are
fighting it out over crt and transgender
ideology being taught in the classroom
big tap flip-flopped on their band
regarding the origins of coven 19.
the us is currently a laughingstock on
the international stage with their
recent army commercials
well we're going to talk about all those
things tonight join me jeremy boring
michael knowles and andrew clavin
tonight
for another cigar packed session of
backstage it streams at 7 00 p.m eastern
6 pm central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel dailywire
don't miss it
also in 1948 clarence thomas was born
into dire poverty in the segregated
south by 1991
he was fighting a contentious
confirmation battle that ended in his
rise to the supreme court he's currently
the most important justice
in america he has been for quite a while
and now we're told his amazing story in
the film created equal clarence thomas
in his own words if you haven't seen it
i highly recommend watching it right now
at daily wire despite the film's
popularity amazon inexplicably removed
it from its streaming service
during none other than black history
month because it's one thing to have
black history month center on like
michelle alexander it is another
thing for black history month to center
on you know actually important figures
in american history like clarence thomas
lucky for you the daily wire has decided
to step in and stream it ourselves so
get your popcorn ready because you can
now stream created equal any time it's a
super important film it's really
terrific it's available to dailywear
members over
at dailywire.com if you're not yet a
dailywire member join now
at dailywire.com subscribe with
codejustice for 20 off your membership
get ready for a film unlike any other
once you remember be sure to check out
all of our other great content we've got
candace featuring candace owens or our
first film run hide fight or my new
series debunked where i debunk leftist
myths in 15 minutes or less
you can get all of this and more on
demand by going to dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20 off using
code justice
don't wait start streaming today also if
you are watching this
on youtube make sure that you hit that
like button make sure to subscribe below
make sure you hit that ding on the
notification so you're notified whenever
we have
a new piece of content you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so joe biden has an answer to the crime
question as well so we've had a few
answers for democrats
one is it's not that bad right really
it's not that bad
i mean we've got that from merrill
bowser in washington d.c and lori life
in chicago it's all in your imagination
all those dead bodies on their streets
you're just imagining that guys i mean
that's not real that's not real
okay part two of this argument is
actually
actually we never called for defunding
the police that
again figment of your imagination we
never were anti-cop
in fact gensake goes republicans who are
anti-cop
you know how you know they're anti-cop
you know that they're anti-cop because
republicans are gonna defund the police
okay and then
you get to part three and that is it's
not a crime problem it's a
gun crime problem it's about the
guns now there's a complicating factor
in the it's the guns
problem there are a few one the places
that are experiencing the highest levels
of
violence right now are in fact major
american cities with heavy gun control
chicago washington dc new york
los angeles seattle none of these places
are exactly red state gun havens
these are not places where there is a
gun propped over the mantle piece
in every home next to a buck's head or
something
it's not what's going on number two the
number of guns in circulation in the
united states has been going steadily up
over the course of the last 20 years the
crime rate was going steadily down
and then democrats took control of these
major american cities
and decided that they were going to
actually reverse all that progress
remember
new york city was effectively governed
by republicans up until the end of
bloomberg
at least with regard to crime same thing
in los angeles
up through the end of richard riordan
and then it started to reverse itself
and same thing in in some of these other
major cities where
while there may have been democrats
governing these democrats were at least
friends with the cops right i mean
they were big with the they liked the
cops they had good relationships no
longer right the moderate democratic
party is dead
and so now they have to come up with
some sort of alternative explanation for
why reality is not complying with their
demands that reality change
and there is this odd sort of need among
democrats to completely ignore the
realities of life
in order to present the ideology that
they espouse as being practical
you saw this with obamacare that
obamacare kicked into place
and suddenly restaurants were like okay
you know what it's going to cost us more
money because now we have to cover
certain things we didn't have to cover
before and so we're going to give you an
obamacare up charge
and people get angry at restaurants for
noting this how dare these restaurants
note this
how dare they right or you see the
minimum wage minimum wage rises in a
particular city
restaurants start to go out of business
or they raise their prices and they
notify their customers the reason that
we're raising our prices is because the
state is forcing us to spend more on
labor
and democrats will be like how dare they
let you know this remember there's a big
issue in seattle
just a few years ago okay so now it
turns out
that human behavior does not comply with
democratic demands
crime goes up when you get rid of the
incentive for crime to go down
so joe biden has to come up with a
plausible alternative his alternative is
it's the guns the guns have just they've
gotten really violent lately
like before those guns they're just kind
of sitting there as inanimate objects
but lately
for no reason that we can discern those
guns have basically gotten up started
walking around on their own
like the little brooms in the sorcerer's
apprentice from the original fantasia
they just
going around shooting black people for
no reason and that's that's the problem
obviously it's the guns guys
so the answer to that therefore is a gun
crackdown
on people who illegally own or use guns
unless their name is hunter biden and
they're snorting parmesan cheese and
also their girlfriend is taking their
gun and throwing it in a dumpster
and then you call secret service to
clean it up if that's the case then you
just leave it alone
right that's that's not a gun criminal
hunter biden hunter biden is the
greatest and smartest person joe biden
knows
it is all of you you and your gun
ownership
you and your law-abidingness you made
it's like white supremacy you might
think
that you're not a racist secretly you're
a racist because joe biden says so
you might think that you're a normal
law-abiding gun owner secretly however
the criminal lurks within and and it
didn't until you bought the gun now that
you bought the gun
well i mean all all bets are off whoa
hey so here is joe biden slurring his
words and saying nonsensical things
as per his usual arrangement his his
continuous battle with the teleprompter
just maintains eddie worked as a
violence interrupter
now he runs a program that provides
high-risk men with cognitive baby
cognitive behavioral therapy to help
them
react to the impulses by slowing down
rather than following through on the
violence
it puts them in he puts them in paige
jobs to
change their trajectory the program has
reduced
has reduced shootings by 40 percent well
we give him cognitive kubernetes and
then a cream await
lin's matlock here's the president
getting into his actual policy as
opposed to just
generally slurring his words like a
patient
who needs to be returned forth with to
his uh to his
hospice room here's the president of the
united states claiming it's untrue that
blue cities have the worst gun crime
the gun lobby wants you to believe that
cities that are the toughest gun had the
toughest gun laws
still have the highest rates of gun
violence as is pointed out by the group
we had today in our round table
the the violence is so they argue why do
you need those gun laws if they don't
work in cities that have tough laws
don't believe it here's the truth
today's conversation with mayor scott in
baltimore for example echoed
what we know to be the case and hear
from mayors all across the country
mayors have the power to help shape and
enforce the laws in their cities
but they can't control the laws in
neighboring cities and states
even though the gun legally bought there
is often ends up in their streets
so i love the logic here the logic here
is yeah sure it's true we have these gun
control laws in our cities
and we have the power to control our
cities but we have no power to control
our cities at all
none right it's all coming from the
outside so presumably
you know we share this giant border with
mexico as it turns out this huge border
with mexico
so let's say that the biden
administration were to crack down on gun
dissemination in the united states
and then guns started flowing over that
border presumably
you can make the same claim oh my god
the gun crime in the united states it's
due to the
to that border so probably we should
invade mexico like what are you talking
about
what are you talking about you tried
your gun control policies in
washington dc it failed either your
mayors have control over the cities or
they don't
if they don't have control over their
cities i would recommend that you elect
a new mayor because it turns out
that when republicans govern these
cities suddenly the gun crime goes way
down
weird weird how that works almost as
though policy has something to do
with the predictable outcome but it's
all the guns it's all the guns
and then joe biden goes into one of his
bizarre reveries we've already had his
bizarre reverie about how you don't need
guns because the government could nuke
your ass which is like
joe biden as slim pickens and doctor
strangelove
come on man
peter sellers also
he has now attempted this line about how
you don't need
certain types of ammunition because
you're not going to shoot a deer with a
kevlar vest he's tried this line
multiple times
it is always stupid because he is
correct deer do not wear kevlar vests
also when a deer invades my home i'll
worry about shooting a deer
when somebody invades my home seeking to
harm me or my family
there's a better shot that the human
doing that is wearing a kevlar vest than
a deer
but here is here's the president of the
united states again being an adult
febrile idiot
there are things we know that work to
reduce gun violence and violent crime
and things that we don't know about but
things we know about
background checks for purchasing a
firearm are important
ban on assault weapons in high capacity
magazines
no one needs to have a weapon that can
fire over
30 40 50 even up to 100 rounds
unless you think the deer are wearing
kevlar vests or something
first of all i love that he prefaces
that i do love that he prefaces that
with there are things we know that work
against gun violence like getting rid
of quote-unquote assault weapons that
didn't get rid of gun violence yet idiot
you can look at the at the decline in
gun crime across the united states and
it continued
after the the assault weapons ban
expired in the early 2000s there is no
evidence
that that assault weapons ban had
anything to do with the decline in crime
you know what has to do with the
declining crime this is the most obvious
thing in the entire world
what had to do with declining crime more
cops copying
right that is what it turns out that
police officers policing things
reduces the levels of crime but again
democrats cannot admit this because they
are ruled by twitter
because it cuts against their ideology
and they are cruising for an absolute
electoral bruising
they are cruising for it and you can see
them reversing this stuff in real time
over the course of the last week
the democrats have reversed themselves
on a bunch of their key issues so to
take one example
the same democrats who are declaring it
as life or death for democracy
to not pass their garbage voting rights
bill which is not a voting rights bill
it is a voter fraud bill it expands the
possibility of voter fraud in a wide
variety of ways
the democrats were suggesting for years
that voter id was a racist tool of jim
crow now it turns out the democrats are
embracing
the new jim crow weird weird according
to the new york times
democrats are reluctantly making voter
id laws a bargaining chip
congressional democrats searching for
any way forward on legislation to
protect voting rights
find themselves softening their once
firm opposition to a form of restriction
on the franchise they had long warned
would be exhibit a for voter suppression
voter identification laws according to
the new york times
in recent years as the concept of voter
id has become broadly popular
the idea that voters bring some form of
id to the polls has been accepted by
democrats ranging from senator joe
manchin
of west virginia west virginia on the
center right
to stacey abrams of georgia a hero of
the left senator raphael warnock
democrat from georgia
said as i've always said a person should
have to confirm they are who they are in
order to vote
no you you haven't said that always but
well
they reversed themselves because they
realized it was unpopular they're kind
of stuck on the policing issue because
it's so central
to their racial equity push to be
anti-cop that they have to find some
sort of plausible alternative
explanation but they're reversing
themselves as fast as possible
on as many policies as humanly possible
like
over and over and over again which is
why of course they're sending kamala
harris to the border it turns out
that that is a giant fail so they put
kamala harris in charge of the border
then she didn't go to the border and
people were like hey look there's a
giant crisis the border and kamala
harris is nowhere to be found
now she's heading to the u.s mexico
border this week why
she's heading there because donald trump
said he was going there
all it took was donald trump saying that
he was going to go visit the border for
the white house to be like well that
seems like bad optics why don't we send
kamala harris there and she'd pretend
she cares about all of this
my favorite is jen saki's attempted
explanation of why kamal harris is now
going to the border we understand why
she's going now
it's to avoid political harm to the
administration here's jen saki trying to
play it off
why is the vice president visiting the
border this week
when earlier this month she dismissed a
trip like that
saying it would be a grand gesture she
also said
um in an interview with nbc that she
would be open to going to the border if
it was an appropriate time she said that
after she said that so that's important
context that's right an important
context i've got the nbc interview right
here
uh she was talking about how but she
hasn't been on the border she hasn't
been to europe
either so does she think that these two
things are the same
uh and again uh peter i think she also
said in the same interview
that she would be open to going to the
border at an appropriate time
okay we all know what's going on
democrats are they are fast reversing
their own policy which is an indication
those polls for 20 20 20
for 2022 those polls they must look just
terrible
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
today he discusses the death
suicide of john mcafee you can hear more
details about that story over on
michael's show that is available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
president biden wants to take away your
guns the irs
is being weaponized against christians
and against conservatives
and a wikileaks drop shows that then
secretary of state hillary clinton had a
strong suspicion about bio weapons at
the wuhan institute of virology
a dozen years ago so strange that we
hadn't heard about that
check it out on the michael knowles show
you